it is time
for summer game fest the official live
stream put together by jeff keely
key three as we're calling it if you
you can buy an e3 and keely cause i
guess there's no e3 this year this is
our alternative um of course also
getting devolvers this afternoon capcom
monday xbox bethesda on sunday i'll be
doing reactions to all of them but um
this is probably gonna be the most
varied show that we get
and i'm excited um i know that jeff
keeley did say temper expectations
and that this is largely going to be
games we already know about um or
footage of games that have already been
announced rather than new reveals and
i'm totally cool with that it's cool
with me
i don't have a ton of predictions really
um i want to see more of callisto
protocol
and
there's some last of us news that i'm
just sort of
expecting
uh that i haven't seen any footage of so
let's do it
i
am excited
and also very small that maybe seems
like the right size i don't know
i feel like my face is too zoomed in
most of my reactions so it's like what
if i
step back a little bit
all right
five seconds
and i'm not sure how long this is
because it says it's still live i i'm
obviously watching uh on my lunch break
at work
the following program may contain
content that some viewers find offensive
that is so vague that is so incredibly
vague
i guess you're right but how would
viewers have discretion if they don't
know what specifically that entails
and here we
go
hello everybody i'm jeff keeley
summer games you got it live
live showcase of what's next in the wide
wide world of video games yeah i'm a few
hours after ed i don't know how long it
is
because it just says still says it's
live imax theater welcome
to thank you showcase event over the
next few hours and i'm just avoiding
updates on the games you love be joined
by special developer guests and yes have
a few surprises along the way what shoes
is jeff wearing
i like
industry showcase whether you play on
xbox pc playstation switch or mobile
that seems like a bit of bias in the
order there jeff all right platform of
choice playstation was a big fallback
but that's fine together as one
community that simply loves the art of
amazing video games
the biggest franchises in the industry
are here like call of duty you'll get
introduced to exciting new worlds new
teams and will make room for small
independent developers i love those
legacy's spotlight
if we do this this camera needs to stop
moving so much discover a few new games
very cool sets but please [ __ ] calm
down if you don't get every announcement
you desire let's face it you're not
gonna get everything today but we've got
a lot of great stuff so let's get
started i do like just respect the hell
out of jeff for all of this years ago
capcom street fighter hit arcade
interesting
um his excitement's so genuine he does
this because he loves it has continued
to evolve street fighter six is coming
in 2023 and right now we're character
able to officially confirm a character
coming to the game and show you the
exclusive first gameplay footage i will
actually be playing uh street fighter 6
on saturday so if anyone has any
questions um i think i'm allowed to
capture let me know
and i will do my best to make sure i can
answer those
you won't know what hit you let me have
some fun
let's get this mission started
it's just the most masculine voice on
the planet
i do think this game looks very good it
looks um
maybe a little bit oh that's pretty
oh that's very pretty
from a lot of the commentary i've seen
from the fighting game community people
seem to be concerned that it's a little
bit too similar to five
or not as much of a step up from uh
previously but um i don't feel like i
have the expertise
that's cool as hell to comment on that
uh i spoke about it on the last video
where they featured the street fighter
but um
i can't play fighting games i haven't
been able to for some years
i was very into soul calibur and marvel
vs capcom back in the day but i have
tendonitis in both my wrists so any
rapid thumb tapping i can't do have
problems with some action adventures as
well
um
thankful for accessibility options that
uh alleviate those problems
it's all about the comb all right
brand new game announcement here at
summer game festival okay
check this out
[Music]
[Music]
sergeant leo alvarez of the cm left
recon squad
our mission was to enter the tantalus
base locate the comsat relay and bring
it back online i'm guessing this is uh
we found the relay
but horror
problem another yep
another space horror door closed now
which i will take forever
survival horror is my favorite genre
video game
raiden it
release he support peace
take the lead
this looks very pretty but obviously
just a good cinematic trailer this is
not gameplay
what we found was
a new kind of evil his voice is really
interesting it found us first
what
is this maybe going to be co-op
like uh another left the dead type
man everyone's going hard on alien games
what is this
because they wouldn't do um another one
like uh what was the most recent alien
game
austin did the soundtrack
um i'm forgetting the name of it i can't
imagine they would do another lefty dead
type for alien i don't know what i saw
in there
but i know when i close my eyes
i still see it i would take an alien
isolation too to be honest i don't think
this is that but i would take it
and someone needs to know
what is it
aliens
okay but what
but what kind of game
but what is game okay okay okay
oh it's maybe rts in style
oh i wonder if that's kawa
i have a lot of questions i will look
that up after the show unless they have
an interview for
from the creative forces behind the dead
space franchise today i didn't actually
realize that it was dead space team
first raw game play alongside its
creator glenn schofield let's go the
quote-unquote scofield cut of the brand
new trailer with a little more gore
oh so it's the same
trailer i don't know i feel like he said
that in two different ways
take a look outside
did you know that they call callisto the
dead moon
dead i mean it's very dead space invite
fished you out of that wreck
and i'm happy to be getting the dead
space remake and whatever you're holding
right there
that's your old life
you gotta let that go
because
your
life
is entirely
in my hands
i'm just trying to give you a chance
rebirth
dude
the sweat i wonder what engine they're
using
oh my god i can't wait this looks so rad
i just love that last part
it it looks very very dead space and
gives me chills every time it's not like
it doesn't seem to have its own dna
oh that's cool
the melee weapons
some like gears of war vibes there
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh video games ladies and gentlemen
wow
wow wow wow
yeah let's go
[Laughter]
i can't wait i can't wait i'm 100
playing it what uh engine
sony interactive entertainment llc is
listed first oh that's just because of
the playstation logo epic games this the
youtube ui might be getting in my way
here
i'm not sure
i'll look it up afterwards again sorry
you don't have to
people have complained about me doing
that you know what you wanted to see and
joining me now glenn schofield striking
distance glenn uh first of all
congratulations this game looks
absolutely incredible and i gotta say
the fact that you have built this team
this studio new ip shipping this
december all in covid blows me away so
congratulations super impressive uh
thanks for having us i really do
appreciate it jeff um and you know for a
second just give me a second you know i
want to thank you uh for all you've done
for the game industry uh all these years
man i i think i've known you like 16 17
years now and uh
um you've been an ambassador
um you've amplified new games new
studios and uh what jeff does is really
hard thank you i really do appreciate it
thank you it's not about me it's about
you guys yeah i know i appreciate that
thank you so much and yeah it's so fun
to do these shows and to show this game
so people saw the trailer but what i'm
so excited today is that you just
brought a raw gameplay sequence this
game is in development and people are
gonna be blown away i think when they
see it but tell us a bit about what are
we gonna see today yeah we got a couple
minutes of uh like you said like we're
all game oh we have more okay back
so that was just the trailer with a
little bit more another one
it's actually gameplay great i love this
some
new enemies some brutality some uh just
about everything we were showcasing a
new weapon called the grip it's a like a
gravity gun but it picks up the enemies
and it shoves them into giant fans it
rips them apart quake vibes and uh and
then check out the uh
the nice ending we have where we uh you
know we usually will kill our main
character jacob and in a very unique way
and uh
uh just for a second i i want to thank
the team man like you said through covid
through everything else the dedication
the hard work he must be so excited to
be there thank you very much like not
really having much press around this
either it must be just so exciting for
them to finally reveal this and it looks
like a world class and that's awesome
uh it's it's rare that teams are
bringing something out like this this
year and
let's let the footage speak for itself
schofield striking distance here it is
the first gameplay of the callisto
protocol all right let's go
that is very quick
hmm
i wonder how that works is that built
into his suit or was that built into
that room
like are we gonna see a lot of holograms
i'm gonna play this game so bad i want
to interview somebody about this game
i have questions it's gonna scare the
[ __ ] out of me
okay
all right
okay so he's just like a heavy i'm
trying to see if they have different
it's so dark and see if they've um
like how many different enemy types
we're getting out of different bosses or
whatever
do you have ragdoll physics
it doesn't look like it that's kind of
disappointing
i'm digging the lighting
it is really dark but
yeah there's the lighting of like the
variety of colors
like a little bit of framework
oh my god
oh my god
that just happened wow all right moving
on okay
modern warfare 2 arrived infinity ward
is once again returning to its roots for
a modern day action game and today we're
about to show you the world premiere of
its game play with a level play through
to tell us more let's head to the port
of long beach to check in with johanna
ferris the head of call of duty i think
it's pretty likely that i will play the
modern warfare 2 campaign
hi everyone in 2019 modern warfare
changed everything what a cool an
unnecessary
we are in a new era with that activision
money with the launch of modern warfare
2
we are back we are bigger and we are
bringing the entire team
price
gaz soap alejandro and of course ghost
we needed a stage big enough to debut
call of duty in a whole new way
inspiring on a shield we're about to
enter
oil rigs cargo ships and staggering odds
are just the beginning
here is modern warfare 2.
oh my god that's so elaborate
it's cool but wow
it just doesn't seem necessary
damn
[Music]
i still feel like again nitpicking maybe
because it's just the opening shot this
doesn't
that looks good but this just it doesn't
look as good as i expected graphically
but maybe it's because they started on
water and then water just doesn't look
great
i know it is on last gen consoles as
well this could be a draft
probably going to be a while that
everything is out on both actual we're
set
or at least your third party triple a's
could be gameplay
hmm
that interior looks nice
and this looks very good
the graphics in here
quite good actually
i like playing the call of duty
campaigns on
the hardest difficulty
or close to
because then they really become stealth
games room clear coming up
it's sort of like playing
split us up
and the campaign
hmm
this looks good i guess those like
toilet boxes don't look so great i don't
need to pick it up though we're moving
to the main deck what's your status i
was just surprised with the original
reveal that uh i didn't feel like it was
super graphically impressive just not as
impressive as i would have expected
but i don't
tend to care that much about that it's
just something i sort of expect from
call of duty i think what is he doing
you just you just say wait we texting
what are we doing
just taking a quick break
this definitely looks fun to play
i like i i would enjoy doing this that's
my takeaway but i also i'm like okay i
don't really need to see anymore i kind
of i got it
i think i kind of got it
oh all right
of course red barrels explode thank you
appreciate that
[Music]
i can't break those those rules of video
games it's like something not that long
ago where the red barrels didn't explode
and i feel like i'd been gaslit
it's not the right way to use that
situation still
is the ui really this
where's your ammo
stop that launch
this looks dope i'm gonna be honest this
looks great
back in the water
but again i don't really feel like i
need to see anymore
it is definitely apology
to the bridge fast secure those controls
stop this vessel yeah how do we board
take the ramp
all night
let's have ourselves a gunfight
this is cool
this is very very cool i like this like
as a
a level design they've done here
that's neat
i think the water looks kind of bad but
it's fine it does look bad yeah it
doesn't look good the water is hot
so his hair so his cloth
between them
just like like the verticality of this
you got options
how did you know he was there
it's almost like you've played this
before whoever this player is
i have a feeling you might be intimately
familiar with this video game
suspicious
sort of lens flare from the droplets is
a nice touch
controls are internal
all right stand back
shadow one going explosive on bridge
maybe you need to be a bit further back
but what do i know
nice back with the upside down thing
it looks really good
but i don't have a lot else that's
compelling to say i'm like i'm planning
to play it i like playing a call of duty
campaign i'm down pre-order now and get
early access to the open beta i'm okay
less interested in call of duty
multiplayer i'm the minority i'm aware
that's what we're talking about and
joining us now up from long beach
johanna great to see you how's
everything it's great thanks uh great to
have you with us and also from uh
infinity ward so
we saw the first gameplay very awkward
okay sequence roll through that
incredible uh all right tell us a bit
about that mission uh where is that set
in the game what are we seeing there
absolutely so um first of all we're
really excited to welcome back uh
captain john price and uh
uh the boys uh garrick um
you know they're not they're not
actually in what we just saw today but
uh they're returning members from 141
and then the other two characters uh
that were you may recognize from the
older franchise that we're reimagining
are uh simon ghost riley and uh of
course uh soap john mctavish um and then
a couple other new characters in here
that we're really excited uh yeah i
haven't really questioned how it works
with the continuity i guess um
first
commander philip graves and uh mexican
special forces uh colonel alejandro and
alejandro i gotta say we're it's a
character we're really excited about
he's a guy who's super capable and a guy
who's just as important as test course
141 um but as far as the level is
concerned um you know this i got a shout
out to iw you know this was a tremendous
collaboration across all of the the
different uh disciplines as you saw
everybody coming together some really uh
motivated devs here and uh you know you
saw the wind and i hope so yeah
animations and the awesome sound design
and of course our new water tech which
is actually pushing the boat in
different directions it's creating a
physically dynamic environment allowing
that is the cover you were seeing
certain cases you could be behind this
cover and then suddenly that cover would
shift and leave you exposed awesome but
it also leaves the enemy exposed
creating this emergent gameplay um so
again i'm i'm very excited just can't
wait that i'm so excited that we get to
show it off today and that's just a hint
of where things are going to go uh
johanna tell us a bit about call of duty
overall modern warfare 2 obviously you
know we're so excited that it's back
this year but you've got lots going on
across holiday what can we expect from
you guys this year yeah we um first of
all thanks for having us here we're just
so excited for october 28th
it's such a big moment not just for
modern warfare 2 and everything that
jeff and the team at infinity ward have
built but it really marks the step
change what we're calling a
transformational moment for the entire
franchise you're going to see
incredible rendering incredible graphics
all the things just within the game
itself built all on one shared engine
now
across warzone and modern warfare 2
going forward of course there's a lot of
chatter and interest about the new
warzone experience we're affectionately
calling it war zone 2.0
there will be um a standalone experience
of war zone for current existing um
players as well so yeah
the entire community there but also
and again i think the collaboration's
just been incredible everybody's so
excited for task force one for one um
warzone coming to mobile as well for
players on the go that's cool we're
we're on steam as you know i mean so
it's just a big moment and there's gonna
be a lot more to see in the months to
follow yeah new thing before we we leave
we gotta ask a little bit about war zone
two i know we just you know we're
showing gameplay here on this but can
you tell us anything there's a little it
seems like there's a little bit of a
tease maybe in the trailer yesterday
yeah when we're seeing that from the
community we love when the fans can pick
up some things um some chatter about
maybe seeing high-rise and other
elements but we will get into the
details of war zone 2.0 for sure it will
be an extension of the modern warfare 2
universe so all the more reason why we
think this game this moment is such an
important title for all of us looking
looking ahead and like we said we're
having a bold vision around the entire
future for the franchise so we're in
we're okay i would like to hear some
more concrete things about what is the
bold vision for the entire franchise
because ecology can often feel very
disconnected thanks johanna and jeff um
all right well we've got lots more
summer game fest still to go and now
it's time to announce a classic pc
gaming franchise is coming back with a
sequel over 30 years after its first
release
i love this game when i was growing up
so i'm honored to share this very first
look
i can't even guess what it would be
[Music]
i think
[Music]
i'm definitely wrong i'm trying to map
games that have been out for 30 years
and i was like no that can't be right no
it's not that no it's not that
this is a banging song
he looks like cloud
claude from uh
gta 3
[Music]
i've not played flashback
i'm not even 30 years old that [ __ ] is
older than me
that looked cool
i love a retro shooter
miami-ish back in 2017 we announced
witchfire at the game awards almost five
years later i am so excited the team at
the astronauts in poland has put
together an in-depth look at the
gameplay of this dark fantasy first
person shooter which will enter earlier
soon i am so excited to play this i
would have been at the game awards that
year but i don't remember
[Music]
a long time ago
okay
all right
okay i'm getting i'm getting dark tower
elden ring vibes all right okay
interesting start
all right let's go
yeah terrible aim one of them was
[Music]
interesting
some dishonesty
type powers going on here
[Music]
there's definitely some doom
okay this looks sick
nice lovely love a chain uh upgrade
there
definitely an upgrade so there's gonna
be a skill tree
this looks cool as [ __ ]
i feel like i would like more enemies or
at least to see them be more aggressive
though i suppose this is um
it's gonna say
it's better to show
the player being
very offensive rather than getting owned
uh yes dude
that looks awesome
yes
that looks rad
i will take it thank you
hell yeah
okay next up comes an ambitious new game
from a new independent studio in europe
starring some very familiar names enjoy
this world premiere new game
announcement
world premiere
new game announcement
taylor medlog oh trey baker
29 of course yes
today um
i can't believe what i saw
it's funny when you do a podcast with
somebody for 104 episodes now
[Laughter]
you hear their voice and you go oh yes
troy
speaking of which the next episode of
play which listen is out tomorrow and uh
focuses on uh troy's episode of
uh love death and robots it's a good
episode
i hope you'll watch it
on this very youtube channel
so this is another
space horror vibe
we're getting here which again i will
take
this also looks dead spacey
something is going on here
and i need to find out what it is
oh roger that's um
uh i remember roger and troy taking a
picture together that must have been for
for recording that that's something
brand new and look who it is
troy and roger in person guys rhonda did
tell me he was going to be in la and i
didn't i didn't even think to ask why
what a cool team
good to be here i gotta ask you guys uh
who are your characters in this game
well i get to play a character named
wyatt taylor as a medical officer who's
stationed at this base fort salas
and uh it's the epicenter of this
mystery that we'll discover and uncover
as we go through the game and of course
my character will be at times in
opposition with
roger's character
the battle we've been waiting to see
every once in a while yeah yeah oh man
we can't wait to show you what we've
been working on and by the way roger's
so lovely like so great to be most
people
who know my channel already are familiar
with trolling who's also lovely but
roger is like
one of the first quietly just a
wonderful human being he's so [ __ ]
nice on a remote martian mining post
okay his job is to make sure that uh he
plays awesome morgan and renter
on their graveyard shift the graveyard
shift meaning mars and earth are really
far apart from each other in their
orbits around the sun so help is not a
simple call away
uh i gotta ask i think a lot of people
will see this thing and they'll probably
wonder
you know it's a new team right uh you
know independent studio in europe that's
making this but with huge production
values i'm curious like how did you guys
get attached to this tell us a bit about
the background i i will say that 2020 to
me was the most impactful year for games
it was the first i mean obviously we had
this unprecedented event with the
pandemic and that forced the way that we
looked at everything as a society but
also the way this industry functioned it
was also brand new consoles we had more
tools that were being made available
that were leveling the playing field
between like the aaa studios and the
indie stews of the triple i studios and
so just like anybody else we got reached
out uh james tinsdale with this brand
new studio said we'd like for you to uh
consider being a part of this game and
he walked me through a very brief
description of what the experience was
going to be like and
at the very beginning he said
it's we want this to feel it's a tight
thriller we want it to feel like dead
space meets uh duncan jones moon and i
was like sign me up i'm into that
absolutely good vibes good vibes like
performance capture and everything
absolutely new studio brand new energy
and of course
i get to work with one of the best in
the business and me i get the privilege
who's the other getting to see this guy
and watch him in action i know i love to
work and i love the challenges and all
the new innovations that this medium
provides to performers we can't wait to
show you what we've been working on i
think it's going to knock you out i
guess i've seen some of the behind the
scenes and the performance capture on
real engine five i mean this is it's
just like just so nice to see the two of
them about the game what are we gonna do
yeah the verbs are always important so
we're gonna let the game speak for
itself we'll be showing you more later
on but uh this is a game where you as
the player you're going to be exploring
you're going to be discovering like we
said it's a very tight thriller so
that's appealing fast pace through this
world you'll be multiple locations
multiple ways for you too i wonder if
that means first which we're excited to
show you about uh and then the the
narrative is a huge element to this the
they they didn't waste uh any any
resources on the the performance for
sure i gotta tell one quick story if i
can um that was one of our favorite
moments
um there is a lot of action in this game
and that was at the the forefront of
this
and to speak to the performance capture
aspect we brought in an incredible i
gotta give him a shout out to nathaniel
our stunt coordinator who walked us
through and really approached us in a
completely different way than anything
i've ever done before and he says i want
to know the story of this fight and so
roger and i sat down we said these are
where our characters are and he goes
give me one hour and i will come back to
you with the story of this fight and
after an hour he comes to us and he goes
it was like a like a recovery program it
was 12 steps and he walked us through
this incredible fight and i about
halfway out halfway through i started
tuning him out and i was like hey man i
just want you know i've got no ego about
this but i can do a lot of things but i
i can't do this and he grabbed me by my
shoulders and he says oh you can you
will and it's going to be glorious
and we did a dance it was a lot of trust
and it worked out yeah i mean we're
excited
yeah i mean this is so cool to see is it
in independent studio doing this teaming
up with you guys we can't wait to see
more troy roger thanks yeah very curious
like what differentiation differentiates
it from dead space guys all right well
next up
it's gonna have a lot of similarities
between the two of them a very exciting
new game
will feature a musical score by industry
legend mick gordon this one is gonna
grab you and we are so honored to debut
it
[Music]
hmm
this is another horror game
what a what a like what a great time for
me specifically
i will take it
yeah this also has like alien vibes
hmm
was a terminator
i'm a big fan of this sound design
[Music]
that looks cool
routine okay
i feel like this oh it's real fury
nice
um i feel like the showcase is just it's
very great that was routine coming to ex
games i will be playing just a decade
ago
now officially back i can't wait to see
more oh yeah now it's time to check in
with a very special guest who's been in
his fair share of video games including
most recently it's trey baker again
fortnight as the foundation dwayne
johnson
welcome to summer game fest how are you
what's up everybody and what's up jeff
and what is up to the
summer game fest audiences live
streaming right now around the world
everybody inside the epic imax theaters
dwayne johnson here coming at you from
my iron paradise
the very hot
and sweaty
and smelly iron paradise uh powered by
of course zoa energy the number one
fastest growing energy drink in the what
is happening here you guys know me uh by
a lot of nicknames the rock
la roca in spanish
is this just an ad sexiest man alive uh
big drink energy
always room for a cheesy joke there's
always room for the extra large cheese
what the [ __ ] is happening i deliver
them often uh
you guys also know me as the
greatest and most electrifying surprise
in gaming um you know me as the
foundation
and i got to tell you this is going to
lead into fortnite thank you so much for
the crazy response is this an ad the
foundation but also
i got to say that you know i've had such
a pleasure uh working with um epic games
and uh the teams over there and we
cannot wait to show you why is this
happening and speaking of the future in
the future you will also know me as
black adam
black adam as millions yeah we know
around the world who know the black out
of mythology what is happening
is unstoppable why is this happening
what um black adam has the powers of
superman but the only difference well
there's a few differences but one of the
biggest differences is superman can this
be over maybe
we like the rock
we don't want any of this
so you do the math uh october 21st i
cannot wait for you guys to see black
adam around the world in theaters only
and you guys will finally see the
hierarchy of power in the dc universe
okay
uh it has been an honor
to become black adam and it was a okay
it is a role that's in my dna and that i
was born to play i was born to play the
man in black and i'm honored to show it
to you guys on october 21st so until
then uh
stay healthy stay safe
stay focused
keep having fun keep kicking ass uh
enjoy your gaming and i'll see you down
the road
this is black adam
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i'm not even going to ask questions i'm
just going to pretend that didn't happen
i'm just going to erase that from my
memory
then i was reborn a god
[Music]
you can be the destroyer of this world
wow you can be your savior
he does look extra jacked
that's up to you
did he just catch a rocket
that was pretty rad
[Music]
but also why is it here
is that sponsored i don't
[Music]
oh that's why he had to bring up
fortnight
nope outright it's my bad my bad my bad
he was like is that gonna tie into a
black adam being in fortnite maybe he
already is i don't know
i enjoyed that right
i do not remember the outright is
looking this cool though
or this destiny
yeah i had fun playing with friends
i think that was another game that i
played with lawrence bruce and steve
actually
[Music]
[Applause]
they've gone very colorful with this huh
[Music]
i just feel like it's more yeah it's
more um
bright neon than i remember she looks
kind of like a magic the gathering
character
looks cool
noted
all right
are these ads
i'm a bit confused about
is this an advert
or are these reveals
this has to be an ad
but then wouldn't he have to disclose
i'm not sure
[Music]
i actually just got the switch oled
the dock is so nice
[Applause]
thank you so much
[Music]
this is very cute
[Music]
mix it up
[Laughter]
it's strange though
how little it advertises for guys
yeah i guess that probably works for
like
you're more
[Music]
casual audiences that's a cool app
courage and ray and that fall guys
people also true play and download fall
guys for free starting june 21st across
all platforms including nintendo switch
xbox pc and playstation all right back
to another new game announcement we're
going to announce a brand new game and
universe from a new team of legendary
developers check this out
[Music]
a lot of new studios announcing stuff
here huh
i've seen the aurora borealis
and it is
the [ __ ] coolest go see it go to
alaska it's incredible
[Applause]
signals breaking up command i'll do one
last scan see you soon over
okay
hurry
looks a little like recoil
i'm sure it has nothing to do with
recoil but just the
design making me think of recoil
[Music]
command i
may be on to something
this is probably gonna be like an action
adventure i would guess
of some kind
[Music]
i have it command repeat i have it
mission accomplished
i don't think this is also going to be a
horror game no it's official more of an
action
adventure type obviously cinematic
trailer this isn't gameplay at all
who did that
oh
my friend
it might not even be an action adventure
it's kind of hard to guess with some of
these like this could be an rts this
could be a mobile game they get people
getting real good for trailers these
days
no idea
[Music]
nice
glad you could make it we gotta move
now
there's a storm coming
but what is game
full
trailer what is game
but what is game
what game is
maybe jeff will tell us
okay we have it tim congratulations
stormgate is real we have a name and
some details uh so first of all
congratulations on this announcement
second of all about the return of rts
brand new yes franchise what is a
stormgate that makes sense all right so
stormgates are portals that open during
a massive solar storm that unleash the
infernal host on future earth okay of
course yes and we saw some hints of some
i mean you know you guys coming from
blizzard and starcraft everyone wants to
know about races uh you know tell us
about the sides in the search oh i
didn't know that okay yeah we're
unveiling our first two factions today
but there will be more uh so the human
resistance and we saw an archaeologist
from the human resistance in that
intro cinematic and then also the
infernal hosts who are these demon-like
monsters who come from another world
i think one thing everyone wants to know
about especially your background
pedigree of the team of you know where
do you want to push the rts genre it's
something we've all loved for decades
but you know opportunity for a lot of
innovation um i know you're going to
show us yeah opportunity for a lot of
innovation is a good way to say it a lot
of rts can feel kind of similar they
made an unreal engine but i don't play a
lot of rts i've played a lot of age of
empires as kid absolutely i do like xcom
first otherwise not a lot we are very
consciously trying to stay true to what
players already love about it be my
least favorite genre of video game but i
still can get into something really
trying to push the genre and be
innovative first off approachability um
for one thing we're free to play uh but
no pay to win no nfts nothing like that
um just to
lower that barrier to entry to get
players in but we're also really trying
to be a lot more social um so you'll be
able to play the campaign cooperatively
we've got three player open-ended co-op
um we've even got three versus three for
competitive multiplayer but of course
we've also still got 1v1 competitive and
as a little surprise i think we've got
some first kind of working products very
late 50 minutes in but i just realized
how much of the um very much still
captions and being worked on
some shots of uh actual assets that
we're building in unreal engine five
wow well i i i love it like 2023.
sign up now get ready and i'm just so
thrilled that there is a a brand new rts
franchise coming from you guys and your
background and what you did you know at
blizzard and starcraft we're so excited
about this team frost giant uh thank you
so much for giving us your announcement
today on summer game fast thank you so
much for having us that stage is so cool
all right frost giant storm gatekeeper i
can't even imagine how much time for
another indie game announcement that i'm
excited to share with you high water
check this one out
[Music]
good morning high water dwellers high
water pirate radio keeping you in the
know with our flow
alphaville authorities continue it's
already so endearing that alphaville
elites are planning to evacuate to mars
true or not the one thing we can't deny
is that the world ended on a sunny day
[Music]
no one suspected for coming down
the wave was coming but the sky was
clear
i let it wash over me
[Music]
this is also another one that i'm like
but what is game
okay maybe it's probably going to be a
puzzle
adventure type thing
this is one of those games that i will
almost definitely play
support a smaller studio making
something artsy and cool oh
i didn't expect it to have children
assault rifles
but generally like if that's a shorter
experience
don't know that hard to say what a
breathtaking trailer high water is an
adventure strategy game set in a world
rapids by extreme climate change now
speaking of the world around us the
conflict in ukraine is not far from
anyone's mind impacted the development
of games including replaced from sad cat
studios a belarusian studio with devs
from belarus and ukraine the team had
long hoped to reveal a new trailer here
today but we're understandably unable to
complete the place does look really cool
everybody i just want to say we're
thinking of you and all the developers
impacted by the conflict and hope to be
able to share your work at a future show
conflict is not maybe the right word but
fair an official selection of the
tribeca games festival it's american
arcadia where you play trevor i'm flying
to tribeca tonight with the viewing
population constantly voting 10 p.m
can't wait it's gonna be great become
unpopular you need to start then i
literally fly back on saturday morning
for summer games first play days
i'm gonna be
so screwed
just going to new york for a day let's
go you're a city where technology and
science go hand in hand with fun and
entertainment
my grandfather elijah walton had a dream
to build the city of tomorrow that dream
is now a reality and that city is
arcadia
a 43 square mile metropolis where each
it's a really interesting trailer enjoys
a life of luxury and comfort
broadcast live 24 hours a day seven days
a week on every digital platform
american arcadia
control
subject on the run on camera four zero
two five that's a good trailer broadcast
immediately
[Music]
listen to me we can't allow trevor hills
to us that could be [ __ ]
i'm not sure
trevor
trevor can you hear me
be careful and don't make a sound great
trailer
don't worry
well written gives me hope for the game
to get you out of there that is super
[ __ ] cool
again also sort of what is game
i feel like i understand a little bit
more but that is a very apparently we've
made it to the beach next up is a sequel
that we've all been anticipating for a
long time there's trouble in paradise
and watch out you don't want to get
bitten after many years of rumors dead i
finally get an update on this much
anticipation there's no way there's no
way
i don't think that game exists there's
no way
[Music]
okay that's enough it is not dead island
it's this still looks a lot like dead
island
you can't this is like the dead island
trailer thing they did
watch yourself
is this intentional
[Music]
and then the zombies start running
behind you san francisco
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
it's [ __ ] goat simulator
[Music]
this is
are they aware of how similar this is
today island did they do it on purpose
have they seen that trailer
i guess it's a trope in movies anyway
very nice very nice wow weird way to
reveal that what does it have to do with
beaches did they do that on purpose
oh my god
oh god there you have it that was goat
simulator 3 and it's coming later this
year to the epic games store nice now
last year marvel and 2k announced
marvel's midnight sons a tactical rpg
from firaxis games the studio behind
x-com and civilizations heroes from the
avengers and x-men cross over with
supernatural ones like blade and ghost
rider for a battle against lilith the
mother of demons today we've got a look
at some new folks set to join the battle
it's only your watch
love me some venom
this be one of my one of my favorites
back in the day back when i read a lot
of comics not so much anymore now i just
try to do batman because i kind of got
overwhelmed
there's just too much to read all the
time
i've stopped reading as many marvel
comics
i'm into it typical parker luck
i'm gonna need some backup
i feel like
this is also like just not adult
gameplay obviously
yeah i'm not super interested in this
game but
it's a pretty it's a pretty trailer it's
just so weird how not indicative of
actual gameplay some of these are
master of puppies
he's got very cute
cool
counting on you again old friend
three
two
one
[Music]
that used to always work well it did
that one interesting this means
spider-man it's not going to be on xbox
that was we knew about this we knew that
the wonderful world of cuphead the
delicious last course and can you
believe it
saying that i meant to finish the game
before this came out
which i haven't i'm very close i'm in
the last aisle
maya maldenhauer from studio mdhr so
first of all maya it's really coming
it's really coming june 30th on all
major platforms we are thrilled well i'm
so thrilled too that uh i think all the
fans can't believe that this is here and
i've been lucky enough to play this
actually on my steam deck uh last
weekend you guys gave me a copy this
i can't people are not going to be ready
for how amazing this looks and the
backgrounds and what you guys have done
i feel like you've you've amped up
obviously the gameplay it's difficult as
we would expect but the visual look you
guys have taken it even to the next
level so i think was possible
interesting yeah we absolutely did i
couldn't pinpoint one thing that we're
proud of in this because we really honed
our craft took everything to the next
level from animation the backgrounds the
music gameplay design um and of course
our new playable character miss chalice
i'm very proud of her
chalice is fun to play as and even
though this is a dlc it feels like it's
its own game it's kind of been hyped up
like that i would say it is it is
definitely yeah you just get to get on
the island and there you are into this
new uh new territory which is yeah it's
our biggest island yet super super-sized
bosses lots of secrets to discover um
don't let any rock go unturned yes and
lots of challenge ahead well i know you
brought i i know you wanted to you don't
want people to necessarily have too much
about the game but you brought a little
something a little something yeah it's a
brand new gameplay footage of one of our
new bosses mortimer freeze it takes
place in an icy arena something on my pc
just made a noise i don't even know what
that was um attacks and transformations
we hope everyone enjoys it all right
let's check it out cuphead the delicious
laughs i didn't get a pop-up or anything
no idea what just made that noise
i mean this still looks like cuphead
[Music]
which is good cuphead is super creative
[Music]
but i feel like maybe jeff might have
assaulted that it doesn't look like a
completely different game
unless i'm under selling it in my head
[Music]
oh that's cool that's a like uh super i
forgot what it's called
yeah get your parries in on them pink
ones
[Music]
i'm sure that won't be that easy
now if you want even more cuphead and
who doesn't tomorrow we will show you an
exclusive look at season two of the
cuphead show when i co-host netflix's
geeked week which will include new show
and game announcements it streams at 10
a.m pacific 1 p.m eastern
and that's not all there's more summer
game fest all weekend long coming up
next the day of the devs indie showcase
with i am 8 bit and double fine then
devolvers marketing countdown to
marketing tomorrow afternoon
there is the epic game store showcase at
11 a.m pacific 2 p.m eastern
news on rocket league
and the tribeca game showcase and sunday
don't miss the xbox of bethesda yeah
we're ready with a look at the fact
i know it's unlikely now we have some
exciting i would love to switch and pc
fans about neon white a game where you
play an assassin from hell who slays
demons for the chance to ascend to
heaven
i think i'm booked to play this on
saturday
[Music]
i think i think i am
this is one of the games that i'm
checking out
hopefully i'm not mistaking that
we're called neons
sinners plucked from hell to do god's
dirty work
but i'm finding it hard to believe we're
in heaven
it's an interesting concept
it's also a very unique looking game
new day new mission from all mikey
you think you can win me over by
showering me with gifts
[Music]
that's a cool way to end that that's
very neat
very stylish
yeah i think i might be playing it i'm
not positive
we've shown you lots of games today made
by huge teams thank you very much it's
time for a game made by a single father
in poland
over the past year he's brought on some
help to bring his vision for a
fast-paced action game midnight fight
express to life let's take a look cool
[Music]
okay
okay
i'm already into it get knocked down get
up again that whole spiel
well it's time partner
time to rise up
together
[Music]
this looks like a very alana ass video
game with it well i side of the side see
lives as dollar signs
like uh yeah hotline miami sifu
type no not him
feels like that should be a genre of its
own
metroidvania should be like a
into it into it oh day before my
birthday
my my
such a cool game and i'm happy to
announce that a pc demo of this game is
going live right now on sweet will be
part of the steam next fest next week i
really want more playable games
at home and that's one of them check it
out all right joining me now is megan
from digital extremes to talk all things
warframe megan how you doing i'm so good
my fellow canadian i know we've got a
lot we just happen to always have these
canadian teams on the show i don't know
how that works out right okay we do well
we have a great connection we've also
done a lot with warframe over the years
and i know right now anyone watching on
twitch for more than 30 minutes this
show is gonna get a special twitch drop
right that's right i already have seen
people getting it so it's very exciting
i have not played warframe i'm loud and
proud but everyone i know who plays it
30 minutes from watching very positive
let me just kind of take over your
special friends
but she is there and she is for you if
you are properly linked up no warframe
you know as i said we've done a lot over
the years yeah i feel like world frame
sponsors game and i know the game awards
con coming up in july which is your big
kind of event of the year to reveal
what's next what can you tell us
well i can't tell too much but yeah july
16 2022 it's a digital event again this
year uh today actually we just launched
the digital items for it so you can get
some in-game goodies some really cool
cosmetics some merch all that really
great stuff went live today but of
course the reason i'm here
is to you know kind of debut we have our
tenno live during tennocon which is our
big reveal of the night and we usually
do a little bit of a game play a little
bit of a demo and i think a lot of
people can suspect what it might be but
i'm here to kind of confirm what it is
that tunnel live is going to show
and what is that
can i say it yes i think you can okay
you're going to get your first look at
the diviri paradox finally finally i
know i know it's been a couple of years
uh but davier paradox is going to be
what tennolive is all about i don't know
what any of this means but teamwork
really she seems very excited and that's
awesome
i'm just really proud and excited to
show it awesome well thanks so much for
being here on summer game fest let's
take a look at that right now
let's take a look at that
my child
i never have a problem watching wall
frame it always looks interesting
maybe i should just so that i have a
better understanding of kind of what it
is
probably what
new choices await us now
[Music]
[Music]
for now
dream of who we were
and of who we have become
[Music]
maybe this is time to get in whatever
the very paradox is
[Music]
that's pretty sick i don't know what
that is but she fancy
[Music]
next it's time for a new look at hong
kai star rail an upcoming i think the
pacing of this is really good yeah a lot
of space today from gentian impact
studio
i don't feel like i've been blown away
this studio continues back to back or
anything but i don't even remember the
last time that happened the very first
time he knew that any kind of e3 will be
able to showcase
but the pacing is really good it's like
it's a lot of
games and then you know just a
discussion with a a dev um
that weird rock bit in the middle
but otherwise i like the pacing of the
show for sure
it's very much just getting to the point
which is great
now listen
you are in a daze right now
you don't know who you are
why you're here
none of that matters
in the near future
you will encounter many perils
[Music]
you will meet companions who treat you
like family
and embark on unimaginable adventures
remember what you feel in this moment
as long as you know in your heart where
you're heading
you will arrive at the end of the story
[Music]
that's the you i like
i like a voice acting a lot
cool i still haven't played gamchin i
really should shouldn't i
i have wine to soothe the souls of
honored guests who is this man
welcome aboard
and that's not all from hoyoverse today
i'm excited to introduce you to zenless
zone zero their next major new ip it's a
futuristic urban action game i have to
say i'm blown away by what i've seen so
far it was announced a couple of weeks
ago and it has the detail of gentian
impact with a fast-paced action style
here is the world premiere of a brand
new look i feel like i'm excited for
that notable characters armed enemies
and world of danger
[Music]
if all of them are wild permanence do
you need to say world premiere every
time
shouldn't it it's almost just implied
do we you know
i'm taking this song
a lot of good music choices today i feel
like
[Music]
yes ma'am
that is my kind of gameplay
this looks sick
also a very well edited trailer
okay
oh it's like vanquish
consider me interested
hmm
you have no idea what that means
one of my favorite reveals last year was
tmnt shredders revenge which reminds us
all of the turtles arcade games back in
the year well it's nearing the end of
development and the team wanted to use
sgf as a developer i think one exciting
aspect of the game they've been keeping
under wraps until now
the release date
patrick
[Music]
oh or is it casey
[Music]
i guess as it is i don't remember seeing
that casey johnson's in the game
last year
i went to uh
an arcade in portland and managed to
play one of the um
old ninja turtles arcade games
not that long ago and it was so rad to
get to do that in person
six players that's awesome
[Music]
there he is
[Music]
they still hold up they are very good
[Music]
it looks very authentic oh it's not
devolver i just completely made that up
nickelodeon of course it is there a
publisher
that's my boy donny
[Music]
there you go damn okay
hell yeah that's awesome
we are getting some clothes stuff too
that's nice and stuff that's coming out
this year
[Applause]
oh
i don't think i know what this is
i get another
cinematic trailer
everyone's hot so
that's always cool
i'm vastly in favor of a hot video game
character
[Music]
[Applause]
stupid people i haven't heard of that i
assume that's already bitten out
[Music]
i feel like i just missed so much stuff
these days turns out working in game dev
really occupies a lot of your brain
[Music]
again some of these kind of feel like
ads it's strange
because i can't
make the distinction
[Music]
oh the mountain king is one of my
favorite songs ever made
[Music]
[Music]
how far will you push humankind
this is just an ad
right i don't i really can't discern
it's probably not important i don't know
why i even care
[Music]
humankind allows you to shape your
civilization by combining
excuse me everybody ancient to the
modern era
one piece is celebrating its 25th
anniversary this year and bandai namco
is bringing the mega popular franchise
back to video games with one piece
odyssey monkey de luffy and his crew of
pirates are off on their next adventure
this trailer reveals the setting a
mysterious island where luffy and his
straw hat crew become marooned in this
exciting upcoming jr 1pr i was going to
say one piece odyssey beach volleyball
the straw hat pirates journeying along i
did watch one piece back in the day
but i have not kept up with all 3 000
it was just too much too much
excuse me
[Music]
oh
i would like to see the jiggle physics
interesting animation style
something like a mix of
2d and 3d looking it could have gone
with a persona but they did not
come on
filled with new encounters
and hidden mysteries
[Music]
unravel the adventure that awaits
in an odyssey beyond imagination
it wouldn't surprise me if that game
ends up being like mind blowingly
incredible like a sleep a hit kind of
incredible
yeah i would buy it
this august soul hackers that people
won't necessarily expect and we've got
your friends listen to the english voice
cast with this quick new look
[Music]
yeah people might write it off as like
just being for one piece fans but i
wouldn't be surprised if it ends up
being an absolute banger
ringo
[Music]
take
[Music]
[Music]
very colorful
so that's our mission then save the
world
soul hackers 2. this is the most video
game title of all videos again
you might be wondering how to plan for
your summer gaming dreams nerd wallet
can help you find the smartest credit
card to reward your gaming purchases at
nerdwallet.com
the epic mega sale is going on right now
save up to 75 percent off top pc titles
with an additional 20 times yeah again
eligible products they're not being a
distinction between what's an ad and
what isn't three games vault featuring
man eater be sure to claim your copy
before that ends on june 6th seems
strange tune in to the epic game store
twitch channel for our summer showcase
on june 10th at 2 p.m eastern 11 a.m
pacific we're taking a look at new
announcements and updates from pc titles
heading to the store this year and
beyond if you like did the video start
with sponsored by like how does that
does it not have to because it's a
broadcast
i don't know curious
i still need to finish that game
on the last level and have not finished
it should go back and do it
you nuts
[Music]
this is actually pretty cool
so i um
play games by streaming quite a bit with
backbone
just like a controller
um has an app and then you use you know
that built into samsung is interesting i
wonder if it's also on other tvs
um
yeah i do it quite a bit and it works
very well but i also didn't really have
any issues with stadia which a lot of
people had i didn't have a lot of
connection issues with stadia
uh i guess that's part of living in la
it's generally internet pretty good
[Music]
cool
oh i know these two i'm familiar
oh is it strikers
you're gonna get hit with the unexpected
in mario striker's battle league in this
no holds good excited to play i didn't
play four chaos reigns supreme so
prepare to do yeah i didn't even really
know that it existed um until the last
it hurts nintendo directions
battle league we'll see a nintendo
switch oh where they showed it i wasn't
like familiar with it at all
[Music]
hi my name is carl and i'm a developer
and mental health singer you know how in
some games with some twitch on monday i
have a lot of friends who worked on this
game but what if you had to in metal
well that's an exaggeration a few the
more intense everything gets and we have
i'm really looking forward to legendary
artists like serge thank you from system
of a down so when head banging isn't
mandatory we do recommend it our demo is
live now on steam xbox and playstation
platforms so go check it out and yeah
i'll be playing it on monday
[Music]
it's basically like doom but rhythm
it looks so sick
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i can't wait to try it and see how
the rhythm mechanics actually work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like i almost want to stop
watching just so that i can wait to play
okay thank you it's gonna be like stop
it
hell yeah go check it out honestly i
imagine that the demo is free um
very very very much looking forward to
playing it on monday
all right it's now an hour and 27
minutes
and right now as i mentioned a demo has
launched on pc xbox and playstation for
you to play for free yeah let's go next
up a new game launches tomorrow the
quarry from supermassive games this
spiritual successor yeah i'm going to
have gameplay of that up in about now
yeah and an all-star probably longer
than i have to explore
those binge-worthy
horror entertainment experiences i might
play through the whole thing people
enjoy choice shapes your story and
determines who lives and who dies at a
campus yeah i got a code on monday first
luck
is today
so i'll have a video as soon as i can
get the most important thing in the
world
[Music]
but if your whole family
you know like
every last one of them decided to jump
down the bottom of a well they're all
just
hanging on the end of a rope
how can one person be expected to pull
them all back out you can't
interesting performance pulling that
rope i'm just gonna fall right down at
the bottom of the well with the rest of
them
hmm
what's the point of that
what oh that was like super compelling
there is a lot more to this than you
realized
so yeah it's made by the team made unto
the one kidnapping uh doctors anthology
family is in on it
you have no idea what's going on here
got a goddamn clue
all right let's do this
i'm excited
to play a bunch more who should i call
says
911
oh interesting they've gone like more
comedy
we gotta get out
i'm gonna enjoy watching you die
this isn't a ghost story it's a creature
feature it's really happening and you're
all in it this is gonna get a little
messy
i just i love that they make these kind
of games them's the rules you noob
it's super massive it's like very much
making back at the game awards we were
proud to like nightingale a shared world
survival cheesy movie video games
basically in canada now it's time to
give you a brand new look and deeper
look at the game including its
innovative realm card system that lets
you impact things like the weather
pattern resources and challenges in its
procedural realms here is your exclusive
new look
[Music]
hmm
you're alone in the realms i'm afraid
the portals are a mess
not even sure if nightingale made it's
very pretty
given how fragile you humans are
i'd say that staying fed dry and rested
should be your priority
if the portal arch is inactive you'll
need to make round cards from rare
resources hmm
once you have realm cards you can
activate the portal interesting so it's
a survival combined with um some deck
building mechanics all things lurk in
the interim void
waiting to get in
be ready with your axe pick
[Music]
now i'm out why is it going to be
spiders man why is always going to be
spiders
[Music]
if these shadows have offended it looks
like some good progression there
think about this
[Music]
looking [ __ ]
i may do that i may sign up for that
the saints are marching in on august
23rd with the reboot of saints row that
we revealed last year at gamescom and
today we're happy to announce the launch
of the boss factory demo across the city
builder which lets you think about
trying to set up your character and
since it's been such like an important
thing to say a lot of fun with this one
check it out
[Music]
guys
you gotta do something to capture
people's attention so what do we build
next
what's her name kenzie
yeah they've always been super detailed
[Music]
don't react to the test of the mess in
the gallery
dinner and a show baby
good chance uh
some people are gonna have some uh
streaming issues with the nudity in this
one
very impressive that's cool that that's
the thing they decided to release as
part of marketing ahead of time
it could be a fun stream try and like
make
based on viewer submissions or something
that could be cool
i love that sainsbury just got more and
more ridiculous like
uh before get out of hell uh
they just went full superhero and it's
great it like it was like having a
modern prototype
you know even that was a while ago now
wasn't it it wasn't that recent
awesome oh i expected that to just be pc
too it's on console as well that's rad
next we've got an exclusive first look
at extended gameplay of warhammer 40k
darktide fat sharks follow-up is this
the critically acclaimed vermintide
series dark tide promises intense
four-player co-op action who say is this
the co-op sorry the fps
for pc on steam and exclusively on
console on xbox
[Music]
[Music]
always very impressive
[Music]
again
access the operations array and use the
cryonic rods to flush the system
preferably before something explodes
head on through the ventilation tunnels
and look for an access point
this way move it
this looks dope
this is not the retro fps
do mask one that i was thinking of but
this still looks rad is this being
pulled up like this too
i'm into it
this could be a fun one to play with uh
rahul and
i'm into that
it looks so messy which is appealing
like they don't
not a lot of repeated animations maybe
those two
that's the first part done
get to the base of the
matrix to work
again definitely still some quake vibes
but
maybe quake did inspire just a lot of
things though what happens going on for
a long time
well hammer inspired a lot
yeah i'm down this seems like a fun
thing to to play through co-op
[Music]
that'd be awesome yeah i wonder what the
different classes are
bloomberg team is known for
psychological horror games like blair
witch and the medium i have played and
finished every single blueprint creation
made completely in unreal engine 5. nice
visceral horror experience it's a return
to the world of layers of fears get a
dose
of this layers of fears
i mean layers of fear or is it
oh maybe that sad insanity runs in our
family
let it
run
yeah i will play every blue team game
i'm like committed to that finish all of
them
but the two layers of fear games aren't
particularly connected
hmm
yeah maybe it's a rebrand it's like
aliens they say it's a tale of sadness
and guilt
of an artist
maybe it
this is going to hit different in unreal
five
to tell
now i see it
all this misery
all this suffering
there was no other way
i'm super down i'm super down let's go
oh it looks gorgeous
yeah just like three days ago oh
oh well that's
this is all in laser fit too
some of that might have been in laser
fit one i just don't remember because i
played it such a long time ago
[Music]
that also looks like laser pizzas
by this body
[Music]
now i break free
hmm
i am interested
um i just like two three days ago
refinished the second time uh laser
fear2 on this october gotham knights
arrived yeah
and it's up to the batman family batgirl
nightwing red hood and robin a number of
friends who wrote on this exclusive new
look let's head to montreal to hear from
executive producers supposedly there is
not that much nightwing but content
devastatingly
hello and warm welcome from wb games
montreal i'm fla marti i'm the executive
producer on gotham knights
today we are thrilled to share more with
you on one of our beloved nights
nightwing
this showcase is the first i'm
definitely going to play this night
series and we're really looking forward
to share more with you as we continue
working towards our launch on october
25th
so i hope you enjoyed the show and stay
tuned
so we'll get just more like character
deep dives potentially
that sounds cool
[Music]
i had nothing
and then this city became my home
its people became my family
gotham gave me
everything it deserves to feel safe
[Music]
he looks super fun to play
yeah i also think the glider is cool
no matter how hard we try
there's always more to too
i'm still so curious about this game in
a bunch of ways like about i mean i love
it
but like how it is a solo experience
i got this bruce
i do want a lot of the character stuff i
hope that they go hard into the the
character development between the four
of them
that's a cool little scissor rolling
yeah i'd take a few more of those with
the different characters
i'm cool with it
that was gotham knights and now we
welcome oh look who it is neil druckmann
from naughty dog
probably going to close with this daddy
dog uh great to have you with us neil
it's been a uh an eventful day on the
internet for naughty dog fans and uh i
think we jinxed ourselves we were joking
about last night like watch the assets
will leak and yes lo and behold that's
what happened well oh it leaked already
some stuff that hasn't leaked that we
have lots to share with people about uh
all things that naughty dog that's such
a shame
it is a you know it's a big month
actually for last of us fans because
last of us one and two both that's such
a bummer june and it's nearing its
two-year anniversary for the last of us
part two which is hard to hard to
believe
yeah it's crazy uh um you know nine
years for last of us one two years for
less was part two and we still hear from
fans they're still sending us letters
and art and these characters in this
journey in this world mean so much to
them
um
and it's it's just been kind of amazing
like last week's part two early this
year passed a pretty big milestone it
sold over 10 million units wow and that
kind of support that kind of success um
we're so grateful to our fans it has
allowed us to grow as a studio and now
we can take on multiple projects more
than i've ever had at the same time
multiplayer thing multiple projects i'll
have to edit that out if so
the remake thank you for asking jeff
uh so one of the things we've mentioned
a while back is what started out as a
multiplayer mode has evolved due to the
team's ambition they really wanted to do
something beyond what we've ever done
before at naughty dog and we felt that
multiple stuff has been solid to make it
a standalone title and over the they've
been working on it for the past two
years ambition has grown and we're not
quite ready to fully unveil it but we're
ready to lift the curtain a little bit
and just give you like an update of
where we're at okay okay well uh what
can you tell us about this new
standalone multiplayer game yeah so uh
we have a concept art that we want to
show um
uh but what i can tell you oh
is that this game is big okay um it's as
big as any of our single-player games
that we've done and in some ways very
exciting it's got a story um the way
we're telling that story is very unique
to this game
it's got a brand new cast of characters
it takes place at another place another
part of the united states it's like a
city might somewhat familiar some people
i'm sure our fans have already figured
it out um
uh and it's it's really a recognizable
bridge yes by vinith agarwal um anthony
newman and uh joe padnaty all veterans
of uncharted and last of us and you're
going to see a lot more of this game
come next year i'm excited next year so
i wait until next year to hear more of
seeing it okay well very exciting that
uh this has evolved and i mean that
concept art looks incredible i can't
wait to see naughty dog's storytelling
fused with multiplayer yeah me too
it's something very curious
okay well um that's not all we also have
something that i've been reading about
on the internet every day it feels like
up in calgary they're filming the last
of us show for hbo right
yeah so uh for the past year um you know
we've teamed up with craig mason of
chernobyl fame and hbo to adapt the last
of us into a tv uh tv show um they've
been filming and uh
it's pretty incredible the stuff i'm
getting probably looking at back at
naughty dog we can't help but feel
emotional because not only is it so good
very much the quality is so high
it's so authentic to what we've made in
the game um and
uh i i just can't i couldn't be proud of
like again craig and that whole crew and
everybody that's up there uh and they're
actually their last day of filming is
tomorrow so the entire series last day
of filming they are filming us tomorrow
craig is up there right now kind of
wrapping it all up uh so it's it's
pretty close it's closing did we get a
release date and i remember you actually
got to direct one of the episodes
yes uh i think that really speaks to the
kind of collaboration and trust that
exists between naughty dog and hbo they
invited me to direct one of the episodes
um i think we have an image from the
episode that actually directed oh okay
we could first look let's take
so you can see uh this is a certain
museum that players might know from the
game
and i really have to talk about pedro
pascal and bella ramsey and not only
directing them but seeing them do all
the other episodes they've thrown
themselves at these roles um for a whole
i'm really looking forward to it
watching the nuance that they bring to
these characters their relationship on
and off camera i couldn't help but think
about troy baker and ashley johnson it
felt so similar to the chemistry those
two actors had when we made the game um
and it really that's great news this is
going to be
something special and i will say i do
have faith in it i have faith it's an
authentic video game adaptation yet well
i mean that first image that they put
out it just i mean it feels like the
video game everything that i've seen
both public and other stuff makes it
feel sort of super legitimate you said
and that's awesome to see uh joel and
ellie from from the front side now for
the first time um so we'll see more of
that at next year that's coming as well
right serious uh you'll hear about it
very soon that's okay i'll say right now
all right well last of us hbo very very
exciting uh and we didn't get to see
some of it a couple actors from the show
who are going to join us we happen to
have a couple actors here that are part
of the show we should bring them up okay
come on up
oh what's up guys hello
surprise troye's back again hello
good to see you uh i'm a little oh this
is the announcement that they're in the
show pedro bell
i asked you out here uh i think people
might have known that anyway they might
have been photos
craig and i started working on the show
almost one of our very first meetings we
said troy and ashley have to be a part
of it um and we're such fans of like the
talent and the help like helping us
create joel and ellie um we felt like it
was so important that they become part
of the show and it wasn't it's it has to
be more than just like kind of like a
wink to the camera and like a cameo
these are real roles that we're keeping
on the wraps for now
uh but man i was i'm bummed that i
couldn't be there with you guys when you
filmed your stuff there's been so much
stuff so like so good on the internet
there's so much like talk about what's
being filmed and i think that's you guys
have kept a complete secret that you so
you were up there and you filmed your
roles by now obviously maybe they did
secrets for this franchise is kind of
old hat like we've had for today
except for the date
uh it was it was one of the hardest
things for us to do is to let not let
people know that because
episodes of play watch listen to the
film
troy was in his hotel room
when i walked out on set
um
to be met with literally every person
that i met on that crew
uh is such a fan of this game so we all
knew what it was yeah i can't wait to
see the show committed to working on
this project because of their fan and
their love for the for the game uh was
one of the greatest it was like i was
coming home
to friends
yeah i i the attention to detail
the crew was amazing bella and pedro are
man
i
they're so perfect and it it we've been
trying to sort of describe that feeling
of sort of seeing them in person
it's it's like
it's like the characters coming to life
but it
it's so much more than that i feel like
i can't fully explain it but i am
so excited to be a part of it and just
i can't wait to see it i think it is
going to be
so good
it's it's i love the story i love
just being a part of i'm so excited
about the series and the fact that you
guys are going to be in it and
undisclosed roles i'm so fascinated how
it's going to sort of
bob and weaving and you know are these
characters we know from the game that
they're playing new characters can you
tell us anything
yes
[Laughter]
so sneaky all right well we're so
excited maybe it's already on twitter
hey all right well
let's talk about what was on twitter
earlier uh today lots of talk about uh
the idea or really what's happening is
it looks like you guys are remaking the
original game and this is like a
ground-up remake is that right that's
right uh we wanted to give i'm excited
to see it i want to see what it looks
like of the first game because it is a
really encumbered by any technology i
wanted to find a way to get even closer
to our original vision and we're able to
do it on the ps5
and pc and instead of talking about it
let's look at it all right let's take a
look i'm excited i'm excited i want to
see it i want to see
it so why'd you leave boston
i have goosebumps
i've been on quiet the adventure little
brother
i reckon it's got something to do with
that girl it just yeah it's straight up
looks like
part two but it's part one
[Music]
you know
i've never been this close
it's the outside so is that everything
you hoped for
can't be any worse out there
it's not a very like common thing to do
um
can it to remake something not even a
decade old but
i fully get it like what neil's saying
that about wanting to be unencumbered by
the tech i cared about it it makes
perfect sense it's good for one thing
get you killed
i can take care of myself how many close
calls have we had
and i think modernizing the game to make
sure that it holds up because some of
that gameplay has aged a little bit i
think
it's good for a lot of you plays
hope you know how to use that thing
i've had some practice
yeah the choice to call it pot one makes
a lot of sense too
it looks beautiful truly one of my
favorite games of the past decade guys
what's your reaction to that yeah we
haven't seen that yet yeah you're
watching it in real time yeah
uh
it's because you did these before i mean
these performances you did a decade ago
yeah you didn't go back in i mean you
used the original performances yeah
actually we came up with a process where
we could take the original
uh animation that we did for the faces
and kind of like retarget it on these
new rigs that have a lot more fidelity
and then the animation
side by sides here just how much it has
changed that you went and you redid the
models and rebuilt everything everything
was rebuilt from the ground out wow same
art director directed the whole thing
from the ground up um but the the great
thing about these faces is that um
they're closer to their original
performance all the animators went and
studied those videos and got it closer
yeah a lot of effort to go into that for
sure what i've achieved before um and
that's just like one of the things and
we could talk about like this brand new
ai like all the combat is like is redone
um
just uh i'm excited about it i'm excited
to play per second all the stuff you're
getting because i did not play that we
wanted to give knowing because of the
show releases they're all all new
players for ps5 pending the remake we
wanted them to have the definitive
version of the last of us
that's super cool
i think it's great for a lot of new
players
played the game
i i actually played it again just to
refresh my memory before working on the
show
um
i was a just a glutton for punishment
and i went straight from playing uh
never playing straight into part two
um and so the last time i played
literally would have been two years ago
since we're celebrating the anniversary
of part two coming out so i mean it
looks like i'm definitely gonna be up
for another playthrough
yeah i can't wait to go back oh i can't
you guys such a [ __ ] good game man
it's such a good game it's it's really
when you play it when you see it in
motion it's really night and day from
what it used to be i imagine that you
know there's a thing of the last of us
to combat but kind of that back in the
last of us once it's the whole like all
the new animation system the new ai
system everything we've learned on like
untreaded four last of us two we applied
to this again to give that definitive
version just to give a quick shout out
uh this project is headed out by matthew
gallant and shauna skye
and you'll hear a lot more about and see
a lot more about over the coming weeks
leading up to the release september 2nd
on ps5
all right and shortly thereafter on pc
we will look forward to not you neil
you've talked a lot about
games directed by other people what are
you directing you still making games
still making games i haven't given up my
my day job
uh
it's a little early to talk about it
maybe if someone in places wants to leak
it then we can talk about
playstation linkedin
do have a new project but we'll save it
for another summer game fest okay
okay well we'll see we'll try and save
it all right troy ashley neal thank you
so much for dropping by summer game fest
and i am so excited that the last of us
is returning as you said in september so
thanks guys that stage is so pretty i
can't uh it's such a critical well that
is going to do it thanks to nottingham
all
right
very special that was a long shot look
at the last of us two hours of where
things are going i gotta get back to
work very very excited about that all
right i felt like continues over the
next few days coming up right now on
this very stream a little bit too long
always is a double fine including an
exclusive new look at the planet atlanta
but the devolver i like the pacing
back-to-back stuff netflix geeked week
which i'll be co-hosting and the tribeca
game showcase and a fair amount of
variety that too a lot of stuff i'm
interested in nothing but like massively
blew me away unfortunately bethesda game
show but that's okay
better to get things that people
confident in the things that they aren't
sure about again in august when we are
back live in cologne germany for
gamescom opening night live on august
23rd and then the game awards will
return in december live from the
microsoft theater in los angeles and
finally i'm excited to share that summer
game fest will return in june 2023 as a
digital and in-person event to bring the
gaming community together cool thanks
for being a part of summer game fast and
remember there are more events and
announcements to come we'll see you soon
bye jeff thanks everybody
yeah i'd uh love to know what everybody
thought
um
i would think probably most people
pretty happy with that
i don't know hard to say i had like a
little bit of the chat on the side but
the chat i guess was like for what's
currently live or as i'm watching this
um
after everybody else
uh
and it seems to be very negative but
that's not indicative of anything
it's like people yelling about eldon
ring like why did you what did you
expect i don't know what you thought was
going to be here
um
yeah a little bit long a little bit long
it happens but definitely like really
like the pacing love that we're seeing
more dev talks and not just back-to-back
trailers i like having that like you
know actual insight from people working
on the games and how getting to see
their excitement that genuine excitement
um live is just also very cool like it
really adds
a nice touch and uh
definitely excited about that las vegas
tv show
all right see you guys next time bye